la jambette par l'axé rivière roche pas
très encourageant nous amène là il y
avait la bouteille ne saviez pas déjà on
savait les emprunts sait pas quand ça va
au toit de la voiture avec ceux qui
viennent ici pensant échapper aux
embouteillages de dillon la zone sature
mais pas les magasins dans ce
supermarché bio la fréquentation est en
berne
cette cliente est venu aujourd'hui mais
donc ça dure vous allez vite et de venir
oui je vais éviter de venir et les
entreprises sont en difficulté
pourtant ben oui ça l'est je renvoie ici
le chiffre d'affaires a chuté de plus de
50%
et l'on se bat pour rester à flot on a
essayé d agir alors le nouvel atout plus
tôt le matin 6 heures et demie plus tard
19h30
on est encore ouvert on a fait une
ouverture le dimanche face ont été
fermés dimanche
on a en plus mis 2 7% pour la clientèle
surtout les bruits du malade et ont
véritablement on laisse déjà des plumes
à haut risque d'en laisser encore un
petit peu plus de sirop mise dans ce
contexte aujourd'hui très concurrentiel
l'entreprise est sur la corde raide et
les salariés invités à épurer leurs
congés c'est vrai quand on a le souci en
fait dû perdre de perdre du travail
enfin bon c'est vrai quand je dis si le
chiffre d'affaires baisse comme on
voulait peut-être qu'on puisse payer ses
salariés
pourtant l'accès par californie n'est
guère plus embouteillées qu'est la
coutume et met beaucoup de martinique et
son de vouloir éviter carrément la zone
illustration du côté des réparateurs
autour semaine en semaine
sa défense à des fins
à faire pratiquement la moitié c'est ça
continue comme ça et si c'est à saper la
moitié ça on sera en difficulté
et pourtant l'entreprise n'est pas en
difficulté avec moitié moins de travail
ce taulier compte surtout sur ses
clients fidèles depuis la semaine
dernière en fait je voulais venir les
voir mais pas pour à cet embouteillage
monstrueux
donc je me suis organisé venir tôt ce
matin mais vous teniez à venir dans
cette entreprise
oui parce qu'une sortie des lieux comme
eux sont fidèles à nous et en plus il
travaille très vite le meilleur atout en
effet une renommée bien établi et un
secteur d'activité peu concurrentiel
comme cette fabricante de rimer brasier
que l'on vient voir de très loin les
gens se sont adaptés voilà on va
continuer à vivre et à survivre à cette
difficulté qui n'a comme aux personnes
mais en faire déplacer pour la sciatique
à la zone chacun s'en sort plus ou moins
avec ses atouts mais qu'elle sera
l'addition dans plusieurs mois